Was meinst du? Ja, Arme schön.
Jetzt. Hallo, guten Abend. Sind Sie der Arzt hier?
Entschuldigung?
Sind Sie der Arzt hier? Entschuldigung, bin ich ja richtig?
Ja.
Ist das die Notaufnahme?
Ja, Sie sind in der Notaufnahme. Ich bin zuständiger Arzt heute für die Notaufnahme.
Das ist schön, dass jemand da ist.
Guten Tag.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Mustafa Aydın. Ich bin hier auf der Notaufnahme als Assistentarzt tätig und möchte mit Ihnen dieses Gespräch führen.
Ist alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, Sie sagen, Sie sind Assistenzarzt. Verstehen Sie auch alles oder sind Sie noch ein unerfahrener Arzt?
Ja, ich bin ein erfahrener Arzt seit drei Jahren. Nein, ich bin ein erfahrener Arzt.
Machen Sie keine Sorge. Ich kann Sie untersuchen und mit Ihnen dieses Gespräch führen und mit dem Oberarzt über Ihre Beschwerden besprechen.
Okay, alles klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Elvira Wünscht.
Können Sie Ihren Nach- und Vornamen langsam durch die Buchstabe wehren?
Mein Vorname ist Elvira Emil Ludwig.
E? Entschuldigung, E?
Emil Ludwig. V wie Vogel, I wie Ida, R wie Richard, A wie Anton. Elvira Wünscht. Kommt von Wünschen.
Wünscht.
Okay, ich möchte wiederholen. Elvira E wie Emilie, L V I R wie Richard, A.
Wünscht, W wie Wellen, Wellen und Ö Ö N A, ne Entschuldigung, wie Schule, S C H.
S C H genau, Wünscht.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Wünscht?
Frau Wünscht.
Ich bin 78 Jahre alt.
78 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. Februar 1948.
Ich möchte wiederholen. Sie sind 78 Jahre alt und am 18. Februar 1948 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Wünscht?
1,73 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
85 Kilo.
85 Kilo. Okay. Was fühlt Sie heute aus?
Entschuldigung, wie war Ihr Nachname noch mal, Herr Doktor? Wie heißen Sie?
Mustafa Aydin.
Mustafa, Herr Mustafa.
Ja, mein Nachname ist Aydin.
Ja, woher soll ich das wissen? Woher kommst du aus dem Land?
Ja, ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ah, also immer diese türkischen Ärzte. Okay, alles klar.
Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja, alles gut. Alles gut.
Ich kann seit zwei Tagen nicht richtig laufen. Und mein rechtes Bein ist sehr schwach.
Und gestern bin ich auch hingefallen.
Und heute merke ich auch, dass mein rechter Arm auch komplett sehr geschwächt ist.
Entschuldigung, rechter Bein und rechter Arm, haben Sie gesagt.
Gestern hat es angefangen mit dem rechten Bein und heute mit dem rechten Arm.
Und heute bin ich auch beim Treppensteigen, konnte ich mein rechtes Bein nicht belasten und bin hingefallen.
Sie sind hingefallen, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie beim Hingefallen den Kopf gestoßen?
Ja, so ein bisschen, richtig. Ich war an der Treppe. Ich bin auf mein Handgelenk hingefallen.
Es ist sehr blau, wie Sie sehen.
Ich kann das sehen.
Ich habe meinen Kopf angeschlagen, aber da ist nur ein kleiner blauer Fleck.
Ok, waren Sie unmachtig nach dem Hingefallen?
Nach dem Hingfallen?
Hingefallen, ja.
Unmächtig war ich nicht.
Aber haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein.
Ok. Und dann, seit zwei Tagen können Sie nicht laufen, ha?
Schon, aber es wird immer schlimmer. Heute kann ich kaum das rechte Bein belasten.
Schlimmer.
Stehen aber ich kann nicht laufen.
Ok, haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ich habe kein Gefühl im rechten Bein.
Kein Gefühl? Ok.
Kein Gefühl.
Haben Sie sich verletzt vor diesem Problem?
Vor diesem Problem? Nein.
Vorher war alles in Ordnung.
Kein Verletzter.
Erinnern Sie sich daran, was genau passiert?
Gibt es einen Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Nein. Es hat langsam angefangen, dass ich nicht mehr richtig laufen konnte.
Ganz einfach.
Langsam angefangen, ha?
Langsam angefangen, ja. Also seit gestern. Vorher war nichts.
Heute kann ich fast gar nicht laufen.
Ich verstehe. Es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben.
Aber machen Sie keine Sorge.
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Wir werden die Ursache der Beschwerden herausfinden.
Deswegen, ja.
Sie sind eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Haben Sie ein Faubarstgefühl, Kürbchen oder?
Nein. Ich habe einfach überhaupt kein Gefühl.
Überhaupt kein Gefühl? Nein.
Könnten Sie Ihren Arm bewegen?
Gestern ja, heute nicht mehr.
Haben Sie irgendwelche andere Probleme?
Andere Beschwerden?
Nein, das ist genug. Das reicht.
Ja, das reicht. Sie haben Recht.
Ich möchte Ihre Beschwerden ein bisschen genau verstehen, was Sie haben.
Und dann haben Sie viel mehr.
Ja, das reicht.
Sie haben recht.
Ich möchte Ihre Beschwerden ein bisschen genau verstehen, was Sie haben.
Und dann haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Überkeit derzeit?
Nein, nein.
Sie haben ja, dass Sie keine Schmerzen haben, oder?
Nein.
Einfach Sie können Ihren Arm und Ihr Bein nicht bewegen?
Ja, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Okay, verstehe.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Okay.
Irgendwelche Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang? Gibt es?
Bisher noch nicht, nein.
Könnten Sie Stuhlgang machen?
Ja, ich war heute Morgen. Das ging.
Okay.
Ich verstehe.
Ja.
Haben Sie...
Könnten Sie schlafen?
Ja.
Haben Sie Ihnen der letzte Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, war alles okay bisher.
Ja, okay.
Und dann haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Chronische Krankheit?
Ja, ja.
Ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Seit 5 Jahren ungefähr habe ich Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Und hatte auch schon mal vor 10 Jahren einen kleinen Herzinfarkt.
Wann? Entschuldigung?
Das war vor 10 Jahren.
Herzinfarkt, ja?
Ja.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Wurde bei Ihnen ein Stand, wissen Sie das Wort, ein Stand...
Ja, ja, ich weiß das schon.
... eingelegt, eingesetzt?
Da ist damals ein Herzkatheter gemacht worden und ich habe einen Stand bekommen.
Ich bin auch regelmäßig beim Kardiologen.
Und wie gesagt, es war alles gut. Bis vor 5 Jahren habe ich Herzrhythmusstörungen zusätzlich bekommen.
Okay.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und dann, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben seit 5 Jahren Blutdruck.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, das erzähle ich doch.
Blutdruck, Herzinfarkt, Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Ja, Blutdruck.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig dagegen etwas ein?
Ja, ich habe Medikamente natürlich, ja.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Das muss ich in meiner Liste mal schauen. Ich habe einen Medikamentenplan. Da steht alles drauf.
Aber nehmen Sie alle Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ja, die nehme ich noch ein, ja.
Auf welchem Arzt besuchen Sie?
Bei welchem Arzt? Ich bin, wollen Sie wissen, mein Hausarzt ist der Herr Müller.
Herr Müller. Und haben Sie einen Kardiologe?
Ja, das ist der Herr Frank. Herr Dr. Frank.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie keine Liste über Medikamente haben?
Ich habe eine Liste von Medikamenten.
Ah, Entschuldigung. Können Sie mir diese Liste zeigen?
Das kann ich Ihnen nachher geben, ja.
Ah, ok. Und damit wir Ihre Medikamente drauf schreiben können, das ist sehr wichtig.
Genau, die Medikamente übernehmen. Ja, natürlich. Ja, habe ich ja da.
Ok, heute können wir diese Medikamente erfahren?
Ich habe sie in meiner Tasche, aber das kann ich Ihnen nachher geben, ja.
Ah, ok. Wann nehmen wir diese Liste bekommen? Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ich habe diese Liste in meiner Tasche. Ja, wo ist Ihre Tasche?
Das kann ich Ihnen nachher geben. Die Tasche ist draußen im Wartezimmer.
Außen im Wartezimmer? Bei meinem Mann, ja.
Ok. Und dann, nach der Untersuchung können wir Ihren Mann kontaktieren.
Und dann, Frau Elvira. Frau Wünsch ist mein Nachname.
Frau Wünsch, Oster, Herzhythmiestöngen, Blutdruck und haben Sie andere Vorerkrankungen?
Das ist ja genug, das reicht. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein. Keine Operation? Ok, sehr gut.
Rauchen Sie? Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol? Auch sehr selten.
Ja, wie oft? Wie gesagt, sehr selten, wenn ich mal auf einem Fest bin oder bei einer Feier.
Aber kaum mehr. Ok, fertig. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Fragen nicht persönlich,
aber ich muss diese Frage auch stellen. Konsumieren Sie ein getwärtsetes Problem?
Oh, nein. Ok. Sind Sie in den Wechseljahren?
Also ich glaube, mit 78 Jahren sollte man das schon haben.
Ja, aber haben Sie irgendwelche Probleme?
Diese Frage ist glaube ich überflüssig. Ich bin seit fast 30 Jahren schon in den Wechseljahren.
Da gibt es keine Wechseljahre mehr. Aber alles in Ordnung?
Die typischen Symptome, die man in den Wechseljahren hat.
Manchmal gibt es Blutungen in diesem Bereich? Nein.
Ok, aber besuchen Sie Ihre Frau als regelmäßig? Nein.
Warum? Ich habe keine Probleme. Sehr gut. Ok.
Und dann, sind Sie pensioniert?
Ja, mit 78 Jahren sollte man das schon.
Ja, sehr gut. Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder? Nein.
Ok. Ist Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, die sind schon vor vielen Jahren verstorben.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte Schlaganfall und meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs.
Brustkrebsmutter, ok.
Haben Sie Geschwister? Nein.
Ok. Ja, ich verstehe. Ich habe alle nötige Fragen gestellt. Würden Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich mache mir Sorgen. Ich möchte gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Ich kann jetzt das rechte Bein und meinen rechten Arm nicht bewegen.
Das macht mir große Sorgen, dass es nicht weggeht.
Ja, ich verstehe. Ich habe eine Vermutung. Ich möchte meine Vermutung mit Ihnen teilen.
Aufgrund Ihrer Beschwerden habe ich den Verdacht, dass Sie eine Durchblutungsstörung im Gehirn haben.
Ok. Was bedeutet das?
Sie haben eine Durchblutungsstörung im Gehirn.
Was bedeutet das?
Sie leiden an Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Zuerst möchte ich gerne mit Ihrem Kardiologen und Ihrem Hausarzt darüber sprechen,
welche Rhythmusstörungen Sie haben.
Deswegen zuerst momentan ...
Machen Sie doch einen EKG, dann sehen Sie es wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich würde auch EKG schreiben und auch Körperleuten untersuchen.
Und dann würde ich auch gerne Herzultraschall durchführen.
Ja, natürlich.
Und dann auch für die Halsultraschall, um Ihre Gefäße zu überprüfen.
Aber wenn wir die Ergebnisse vorlegen, würde ich gerne noch einmal mit Ihrem Kandidaten darüber sprechen.
Ja, unbedingt.
Haben Sie andere Fragen?
Nein, danke. Vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit.
Ich mache mir schon große Sorgen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, aber Sie sind in guten Händen.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Beschwerden verstehen, was Sie haben.
Nach der Untersuchung können wir Sie darüber ausführlich informieren.
Vielen Dank.
Ich danke Ihnen. Sie sind sehr seriös.
Es gibt noch andere Fragen, es fehlen noch einige Fragen.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Zunächst ist das das erste Mal, oder hatten Sie das schon mal?
Nein, das ist in dieser Form das erste Mal.
Erinnern Sie sich an alles?
Was soll das?
Ich war nicht bewusstlos.
Ich habe gefragt.
Ist Ihnen eine Schwerlung auf den Beinen aufgefallen?
Eine Schwerlung in den Beinen? Nein.
Haben Sie Allergien?
Nein.
Vertragen Sie alles?
Bisher ja.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Sehstörungen oder Höchstörungen?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich auf der rechten Seite auch etwas weniger höre.
Das stimmt.
Mit dem Sehen ist es ein bisschen unsicher, aber etwas verschwommen.
Aber es ist mir nicht so gut aufgefallen.
Höchstörungen auch?
Ganz leicht.
Aber das habe ich schon länger.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch etwas Altes ist.
Frau Doktor wollte etwas fragen.
Ja, danke.
Hatten Sie Sprech- oder Sprachstörungen?
Ja, heute Morgen hatte ich ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, die Worte auszusprechen.
Das ist jetzt wieder etwas besser geworden.
Aber stimmt, heute Morgen war das so.
Ich kann meinen Tee nicht richtig trinken.
Das ist ein bisschen aus dem Mund gelaufen.
Okay.
Gute Frage.
Nächste Frage.
Ist Ihre Blutdruck gut eingestellt?
Bisher war das gut eingestellt, ja.
Wie war die letzte Blutdruck?
Beim Hausarzt war die zuletzt bei 140 zu 80.
Sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Blutverdünner?
Ja, das weiß ich.
Das weiß ich.
Super, danke.
Sie haben schon gefragt, Sie haben aber noch nicht gesagt.
Sie haben nach den Medikamenten gefragt.
Die anderen Namen weiß ich nicht, aber Aspirin weiß ich ja.
Meine Kardiologe sagt mir, ich muss andere Blutverdünner nehmen seit fünf Jahren.
Aber ich wollte nicht.
Aber das ist ein Blutverdünner, habe ich gesagt.
Deswegen bin ich bei Aspirin geblieben.
Darf ich fragen?
Aber natürlich, bitte schön.
Sind Sie gegen Tetanus geimpft?
Ja, meine Impfungen hat mein Hausarzt überprüft.
Letztes Jahr, und er meinte, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Danke schön.
Darf ich?
Aber natürlich, Frau Doktor.
Haben Sie schon mal solche Beschwerden, kurzzeitig und vollbegehende gehabt?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Danke schön.
Okay, sollen wir weitermachen oder brauchen Sie eine kleine Pause, Herr Doktor?
Dr. Mustafa, ist er da?
Ja, okay, einfach weitermachen.
Wenn keine Fragen sind, dann machen wir doch gleich weiter.
Bitte schön.
Ich wollte diese Frage stellen.
Ich dachte, dass wir keine Zeit haben.
Eine Frage, bitte schön. Was haben Sie für eine Frage?
Ich habe nichts.
Ihre Kollegen haben die nötige Frage gestellt.
Dann machen wir weiter.
Übernahme an den Oberarzt, bitte schön.
Ich habe eine Patientin gesehen.
Es handelt sich um Elvira Wünsch.
Sie ist 78 Jahre alt und am 18.02.1948 geboren.
Sie ist 1,73 Meter und wiegt 85 Kilogramm.
Die Patientin stellte sich seit zwei Tagen bei uns mit bestehenden, rechts, reichseitigen und rechtsseitigen Arm und Bein Paralysie vor.
Paralysie, Paraplegie, Paraperese, Hemiparese, Hemiplegie, Hemiparese, Hemiparese, Hemiparese.
Okay, das diskutieren wir nachher.
Hemiplegie, Hemiplegie, Hemiplegie.
Ich weiß nicht, Sie sind der Arzt.
Okay, Hemiplegie, Hemiplegie, nicht Hemiparese.
Schreiben Sie nicht, bitte, Lokman sagt, schreiben Sie nicht, okay?
Das müssen Sie wissen.
Hemiplegie, der Unterschied zwischen Hemiplegie und Hemiparese, Paraplegie, Paraplesie, Paraparese, gibt es so viele Begriffe.
Also Sie sagen Hemiparese oder Hemiplegie?
Hemiplegie, Hemiplegie, 100%.
Hemiplegie, also Sie sprechen von einer rechtzeitigen Hemiplegie.
Okay, und dann die Patienten gab an, dass sie wegen dieser Beschwerden hingefallen sind.
Sie haben hingefallen sei.
Hingefallen sei.
Dass die Patient hingefallen sei, ja.
Aber es gibt keine Verletzung.
Keine Verletzung.
Leichter Mikrofon an, aufschalten bitte.
Mein?
Nein, nein, irgendjemand spricht, das stört.
Okay, okay.
Und die Beschwerden haben sich im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert.
Und es gibt keine Schmerzen und ja, keine Auslöser.
Die Beschwerden haben langsam angefangen.
Und ja.
Wann haben die Schmerzen angefangen? Wie lang ist die Zeit her? Das ist ja wichtig.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Okay, können Sie das einschätzen, wie viele Stunden das her sind?
Ja, 48 Stunden.
Ungefähr 48 Stunden.
Ungefähr, ja.
Gut.
Und dann, ja, die Patientin erwähnte, dass sie, dass sie, dass sie, ja, Entschuldigung, dass sie eine Sechsstörmung heute Morgen habe bemerkt habe.
Und dann, ja, begleitend, begleitend klagte sie über, klagte sie über...
Eine Hörschwäche links.
Rechts, pardon, rechts, rechts, ja.
Rechts, ja.
Okay.
Ja, wir haben keine, ja, wir haben Medikamente nicht erhalten.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ja, wir warten auf Ihren Mann, um diese Medikamentenliste zu bringen.
Zu bekommen, okay.
Zu bekommen.
Okay.
Und dann, ja, als Vorerkrankung sind...
Aber nimmt sie, ja, genau, nimmt sie Blutvertöner ein?
Ja, sie nehmen regelmäßig Acetylsalazilsäure ein.
Also Aspirin?
Aspirin, ja.
Sie leiden an Blutdruck, arterialen Hypertonin und Herzstimusstörungen, unbekannt.
Und ich werde auch Ihren Hausarzt und Kardiologe kontaktieren.
Okay.
Und warum nimmt sie das Aspirin ein?
Wegen den Hochdruck?
Wegen der Herzstimusstörungen.
Sicher.
Hat sie nicht einen KHK- und Herzinfarkt in der Hand?
Ja, sie haben vollkommen recht.
Die Patienten, bei der Patienten wurde vor zehn Jahren eine Herzkatastrophe-Untersuchung
durchgeführt, gleichzeitig einständig eingesetzt.
Okay.
Hatte sie einen Herzinfarkt oder war das eine?
Ja, Herzinfarkt, das war Herzinfarkt.
Also das heißt, sie hat einen...
Ja, Herzinfarkt.
Sie hat einen KHK sozusagen.
KHK, chronische Herzkrankheit.
Okay, also eine KHK.
Gut.
Hatte sie... erzählen Sie ruhig weiter.
Ja, es gibt keine Operation in der Geschichte.
Hat sie eine Hahn-Inkontinenz oder Stuhl-Inkontinenz?
Ich habe schon diese Frage gestellt.
Nein, sie haben keine Beschwerde darüber.
Sie haben keine?
Sie haben keine.
Keine Hahn-Inkontinenz oder eine Stuhl-Inkontinenz.
Okay.
Gut, weiter.
Ja, sie rauchen nicht.
Kein Alkohol.
Da kann man von dem verneint.
Und ja, ihr Vater ist an einem Apoplexie gestorben.
Auch ihr Mutter ist an einem...
Oskar.
Mama... Mama... Mama... Mama Karsinom gestorben.
Okay.
Ja.
Muss man nicht sagen, der Vater sei an Schlaganfall und die Mutter an Mama Krebs gestorben, also nicht mitist, sondern sei?
Wegen den Zeiten.
Nein.
Oder?
Aber ich habe eins für Sie.
Gut, weiter.
Ja, das war alles.
Aufgrund von einem decision angabe habe ich einen verdacht auf apoplexy oder tromboembolie
was jetzt apoplexy oder tromboembolie was ist es jetzt kann man sagt ja ich zuerst würde ich
gerne sie haben kein kein schmerzen aber ich möchte mit ihrem mit ihrem was besprechen
welche untersuchungen machen sie gleich als erstes ja können wir auch
auch lkg sie wollen die rythmusstörung sie hat was ist ihre vermutung was hat sie für
rythmusstörung ja wegen der forch auf filiman zum beispiel wahrscheinlich ja genau und welche
untersuchungen machen sie als nächstes bei verdacht auf schlaganfall schlaganfall sie haben
doch gesagt ja tomografie können wir natürlich ganz ganz schnell da wollen sie sehen was für
eine art von apoplexy das ist und zwar ist es eine blutung oder eine ischämische infarkt
ja bei der tomografie können wir wenn die wenn die hemorrhoide blutung können wir auch bei
der tomografie diese blutung überprüfen aber sie haben gesagt hin an ischämie sie haben
ischämie oder ich bin genau ja wie können einfach ich kann nicht direkt in der tomografie
überprüfen sondern mrt oder später ja was ist ihr verdacht mit den symptomen was sie hat
ist es eher eine blutung mit den angama oder ist es eher eine ischämie eine cerebrale ischämie
was ist ihre ja sie haben vollkommen recht aber es ja wenn patient ja ich möchte ihre vermutung
ihre vermutung ok ok was denken sie es gibt keine hinweis auf hemorrhoide weil sein blutdruck
ist kontrolliert auch 130 und 80 haben haben sie gesagt und deswegen ja meine vermutung ist
apoplexy also eine cerebrale ischämie störung sozusagen warum weil sie hat eine kakas
rhythm störungen sie ist schon alt und und und genau also wir gehen von einer cerebrale
ischämie und wo ist die ischämie rechts links links also wir haben eine links hirnige
cerebrale ischämie bei verdacht auf wir haben noch kein ekg aber wir haben jetzt ein ekg
geschrieben sie hat ein chronisches vorhoff flimmern mit einem puls von 80 aber es ist
ein vorhoff flimmern also eine links hirnige cerebrale ischämie bei also nicht genau
chronischen vorhoff flimmern und bekannter kakas ok welches gefäß ist betroffen bei
einer cerebrale ischämie ich die arteria cerebri media ja sie haben recht wahrscheinlich die media
genau ok gut was ist was gibt es noch die diagosen machen wir weiter ja als die
finanzielle diagnose kommen kommen hemorrhoge auch ok interkraniale hemorrhoge genau was
ist auf deutsch
hirnblutung oder einfach eine cerebrale blutung hier hirnblutung und andere
differenzialdiagnosen ja
klar hier das ist alles neubologisch genau was noch was hat man im kopf da kommt von
einem top ruck oder fratoprak eine gute hinweis tumor natürlich ein herr tumor auf türkisch
richtig als ein hirntumor woran muss man noch denken was gibt es im kopf noch was
kann es noch sein ms sehr gut aber ist sehr untypisch natürlich ms so schreibt man das
so in türkisch ein aneurysma ein hirn aneurysma ok ein hirn aneurysma kann so was auch mal
machen natürlich auszocken das ist aneurysma auszocken sehr gut im bett sagt wir sprechen
hier über differenzialdiagnosen was kann alles noch möglich sein genau tier nach
48 stunden nicht nach 84 ist knapp wir wollen also das heißt viele differenzialdiagnosen
haben wir jetzt natürlich nicht das ganze spricht natürlich schon für eine hirn ischemie oder
eine cerebrale ischemie und wenn die symptomatik auf der rechten seite ist und wenn wir von einer
hämeparesis sprechen dann ist der insult oder die cerebrale ischemie links hirnig dann
spricht man von einem links hirnigen cerebralen insult oder cerebrale ischemie und sie müssen
sich wirklich diese begriffe sehr gut kennen und differenzieren was ist links hirnig was
ist rechts hirnig was bedeutet ischemie was bedeutet hemorragi was ist hemiplegie hemiparesis
paraparesis paraplegie tier aneurysma also diese neurologischen begriffe müssten sie leider gut
kennen damit sie das auch gut zuordnen können und die symptom natürlich was ist wissen sie
haben wir die zeit jetzt kommen zu therapie also ich gebe jetzt einfach ergebnisse sie haben
ein ekt gemacht da haben wir einfach auf dem man sie haben die medikamentenliste bekommen die
patientin hat das für 100 hat kann der satan 16 milligramm als amnodipin 5 milligramm und
teurer se mit 5 milligramm nicht viele medikamente nur so viel und das in 100 genau was soll ich noch
sagen genau sie haben ein herzultraschall gemacht der herz das herz punkt gut eine gute lfw funktion
keine klappenfehler kein perikrat erguss aufwilligkeiten und welche therapie kommt jetzt bei diesem
zebran insult infrage was würden sie vorschlagen so erst sollten wir neologische man hört sie
sehr leise jetzt alle links an mir oder nicht an sich genau welche welche therapie ist ja
rechtes was ist ihr therapie vorschlag ja zuerst würde ich diese patientin stationär aufnehmen
und natürlich ja und dann würde ja müssen wir mit dem ja ja müssen wir ein neurologisches
konzil veranlassen aber diese diese passend ist ein bisschen alter patientin deswegen können wir
ja normalerweise dass das therapie hängt von dem alter ab auch das nicht unbedingt nicht
nicht unbedingt ja ist nur sehr fit sie redet so viel ja ich würde gerne hier parin anfangen
auch parin und würden sie die patientin lösieren in diesem fall kann ich nicht anfangen ja wegen
der jeset er liest ja wegen des alters das alte ist kein hindernis ja das ist was ging
eine lüse was spricht gegen eine lüse warum würden sie bei dieser patientin keine lüse machen
ja gegen zum beispiel blutungen in 19 minuten
90 minuten länger oder 80 ich glaube vier stunden oder vier bis sechs stunden ist auch
die lüse zeit okay bin ich nicht schlecht genau vier bis sechs stunden genau also sie sind noch
anesthesist jünger man das müssen sie doch wissen also ja ich will sie vier bis sechs
stunden ist die lüse das lüse zeitfenster wenn sie das heißt die zeit wenn die patientin
kommt nur sagt sie hat seit zwei stunden diese symptome dann denken sie auch eine lüse natürlich
wann machen sie keine lüse wenn es eine hirnblutung ist machen sie natürlich keine lüse wenn es
ein ischimist machen sie eine lüse das hängt natürlich nicht vom alter ab sondern von dem
zustand von den vitalen perameter der patientin und von der wahrscheinlichkeit ob sie davon
profitiert oder nicht das heißt es ist der klinische zustand der neurologische zustand
und die vitalen perameter davon machen sie abhängig wenn die patientin berichtet aber schon
seit 48 stunden diese symptome zu haben und das heißt diese affar sie diese vorübergehende
affar sie sprachstörung ist auch besser geworden und sie haben die untersuchungen
gemacht das ist eine cerebrale ischämie sie die symptome sind nicht sind stabil im moment
aber sie hat eine leichte hemiparesen also keine lüse was machen sie dann wenn sie
keine lüse machen die struktur und genau das heißt die stroke unit oder auf die
intensivstation damit man engmaschig erstmal ja die vitale mit lüstigkeit zu vor ja für
lüstigkeit zu kommen kreislauf natürlich aber das heißt was macht der kreislauf
ist die witter wir sind die vitalen perameter versus die neurologische symptomatik ja blutgas
analyse genau wie geht jetzt die therapien weiter welche medikamente geben sie ihr
was ist ja ein
oder antikorporate direkt oder antikorporate genau ein neuer ein antikorporat neuer generation
was ist der wirkstoff von helikos ist der handelsname ja helikos ist der handelsname
man gibt immer den wirkstoff an nicht den herr ich will keine werbung für pharma firmen
machen ja ich weiß aber ich könnte sie mir einfach an einen hier gucken sie mal in
den da ihre freunde helfen ihnen guck mal warte von der apixel band ja sehr gut
hat der senen hat der senen haema ok apixel band wie oft gibt man apixel band einmal
zweimal dreimal
ein arzt
doch sie sind anesthesist
ihre freunde helfen ihnen wir haben hingeschrieben wir oft gibt man apixel band zweimal wissen
sie auch vielleicht zufällig die dosierung wie viel milligramme das sind 2,5 ja 2,5 oder
5 welches geben sie ja sie wissen 2,5 nicht zwischen es gibt nur 2,5 oder 5 milligramme
normalerweise gibt man zweimal 5 milligramme ok alles klar bei patienten die normalerweise
über 70 sind oder sehr untergewichtig sind das heißt unter einem bmi von 20 oder 25
dann gibt man gerne die 2,5 milligramme aber normalerweise zweimal 5 milligramme ok ich
bin ich weiß also duale antikoaguläre was machen sie mit aspirin machen sie das jetzt
weiter oder nicht wenn sie apixel band geben haben wir kardologen unter uns ja wir können
ja auch weiter machen sie geben apixel band zweimal dann geben sie auch noch
aspirin zwei blutverdünner was passiert dann bekommt sie ihre hirnblutung mensch
ja was machen wir jetzt können sie das genau stellen noch einmal also sie hat ja aspirin
100 schon gehabt ja und jetzt geben sie ja noch zusätzlich apixel band dann hat sie
zwei blutverdünner ja einmal faktor 10 immer und einmal trombozittenhämmer das heißt sie
steigern erhöhen das blutungsrisiko ist das in ordnung blutung risiko was blutung blutung
blutung risiko ja wo sind die freunde wer will den jungen mann helfen ich bin keine
überlegte stopp also ich dachte ordnung wie ich ich kann weiter machen das ist meine erfahrung
aber kein ich bin ich sie haben sie machen ein neurologisches konzil und ein kardologisches
konzil immer auch gut sehr gut jawohl also normalerweise dass sie hat ja eine stabile
kkk und wenn sie jetzt ab fixer band geben dann hören sie normalerweise mit dem aspirin auf wenn
sie denn jetzt ein herzinfarkt hätte oder noch mal einen neuen stand bekommt und sie hat ab
fixer band dann gibt man beides für mindestens drei monate oder sechs monate zusammen obwohl
hohes blutungsrisiko weil sie einen neuen stand bekommt danach nach halben jahren oder nach drei
monaten manchmal sogar nach vier wochen je nachdem was der kardiologe sagt nimmt man das aspirin
dann raus ok sie hatte jetzt sie hatte jetzt ja kein herzinfarkt sondern nur ein vorhofflibern
und dann reicht es wenn man das ab fixer band gibt aspirin raus weil dann erhöhen sie das
blutungsrisiko und das wollen wir ja nicht ja ok jetzt war sie auf das zwei tage auf das stroke
auf das stroke unit sie haben sie an behandelt mit ab fixer band kreislauf ist stabil der
patienten geht es gut sie kann sprechen sie kann schlucken sie hat keine herren und keine
studien kontinents sie hat noch ein bisschen eine leichte hemiparese rechts was machen sie
jetzt mit der patientin schicken sie wieder nach hause nein sehr gut sie schicken die
patientin in eine neurologische wunderbar das reicht jetzt oder ja danke ich bin internist
ich bin kardiologe ich bin intensivmediziner als hausarzt muss man leider alles können
ja ich habe immer problem mit der neurologischen krankheit ja wir hatten keine neurologische
intensivstation sondern operative intensivstation ja ja ja das ist auch so das stimmt wenn wir
diese patienten aufnehmen einfach verlass eine konsultat ja ja wir machen eine konsult ja
aber das ist immer so das ist auch hier in den krankenhäusern genauso wir sind in
einer prüfung deswegen so streng aber normalerweise wird es auch hier in vielen krankenhäusern
genauso gemacht wie sie das auch hat man macht ein konzil der kollege oder die kollegin gibt
eine empfehlung und genauso machen ich konnte ich konnte ich sagen ich bin als ich dran lasse
muss sie mit man mit dem aber erst darüber die sind verantwortlich sie müssen das
okay aber leider ja nicht leider aber das ist ja eine prüfung das ist ja eine sprachprüfung
und keine medizinische prüfung normalerweise aber manche prüfer wollen auch das wissen wenn
sie natürlich grobe medizinische fehler machen ja aber wir haben zum glück natürlich
auch sagen da ist nicht so gut aber es war alles gut man muss natürlich nicht unbedingt alles wissen
das ist auch völlig normal ich weiß nicht wie die prüfer sind glaube die kollegen können
ein besseres feedback geben oder doch geben mir meine also für heute bei ihnen natürlich
ja ja in der schon das feedback natürlich ich wollte nur abschließend fragen haben die
kollegen oder kolleginnen noch fragen oder empfehlungen haben wir alles korrekt gemacht
oder haben wir neurologen unter uns her oder frau toprak kam so viele vorschläge
sind sie neurologen